[Musique]
bonjour boris cyrulnik bonjour vous êtes
un neuropsychiatre et écrivain vous êtes
l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages et vous
êtes en france celui qui a développé et
popularisée au sens le plus noble du
terme
le concept de résilience alors on va
voir avec vous comment votre parcours
s'est construit autour de cette notion
et comment cela inspire et comment cela
a aidé des centaines de milliers de
français à travers vos livres mais pour
commencer je voudrais qu'on s'arrête sur
ce sur ce mot résilience c'est à dire
quoi exactement
c'est un offrant latin qui vient de re à
nouveau sa lyre et sautez re-so c'est à
dire que quand on reçoit un coup ou bien
on est écrasé par le conte n'y a pas de
résidence ou bien rebondi il y à la
reprise d'un autre développement et
c'est la définition de la résilience
c'est à dire en gros comment on se
relève d'un obstacle
voilà d'un trauma il faut voilà c'est
plus qu'un obstacle c'est un trauma
c'est à dire les épreuves dans la vie
personne n'y échappe alors que le trauma
on est sidéré notre développement
s'arrête notre cerveau s'arrête de
fonctionner on peut plus comprendre et
ou bien on est reste prisonnier du passé
c'est le syndrome psychotraumatiques ou
bien reprend un autre développement
c'est leur résidence se dépasser alors
vous avez écrit que vous étiez menés
deux fois et la deuxième fois c'est
quand vous aviez six ans pourquoi alors
je suis né une première fois quand ma
mère m'a mis au monde
j'en ai aucun souvenir et je suis né une
deuxième fois le jour de mon arrestation
pendant la guerre canton j'ai compris
que j'avais 6 ans et demi j'ai compris
que on voulait me mettre à mort parce
que j'étais juif mais je savais pas ce
que c'est ce que voulait dire est-ce que
désigner le mot juif
donc je suis né à ma judéité une 2e et
sept naissances alliés elle a lieu où
dans un quai de gare où vous entendez
qu'on veut vous mettre dans un wagon
pour vous emmener ensuite vers drancy
alors que vous êtes à bordeaux et
ensuite vous des portes et c'est cela
alors ça je ne vais pas compris j'ai
déjà entendu cette phrase
quand j'ai été arrêté chez des justes
qui me cacher pendant la guerre et la
mme la maire de margaux farges qui me
cacher à la mer a dit à l'officier
gestapo en aussi vous le laisser vivre
on ne lui dira pas qu'il est juif donc
j'ai entendu ce mot pour la première
fois et j'ai entendu qu'il suffisait de
se taire pour avoir le droit de vivre
donc ça a été un curieux démarrage une
curieuse naissance à la vie sociale et
ensuite qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous
avez échappé pendant la fin de la guerre
aux nazis à la mort vous avez dû vous
dépassez vous même alors que vous étiez
enfant alors ensuite j'ai été à mon
arrestation je me suis échappée de lacq
synagogue de bordeaux qui était
transformée et des barbelés des hommes
en armes
c'est une transformé en un lieu de
guerre je réussis à m'évader de manière
assez pittoresque assez invraisemblable
mais en fuite
on voulait me rattraper donc toute une
série de juste mon protégé la plupart de
ces justes je connais même pas leur nom
et il m'est arrivé d'en rencontrer un ou
deux je ne reconnaissais pas bien sûr
parce que j'étais enfant voilà donc vous
êtes échappés de cette synagogue alors
que vous aviez les nazis derrière vous
et la milice vous avez réussi à vous
vous infiltrer dans une ambulance qui
vous vous a permis de vous sauver votre
peau d'une certaine façon
qu'est ce que vous ressentez à l'époque
vous souvenez des sentiments que vous
aviez alors je me souviens des images
parce que c'est des images promat hic
elles sont gravées sont claires dans ma
pelle du détail mais le contour de la
mémoire traumatique est ainsi fait que
le centre est hyper précis imprégné dans
la mémoire et la l'entouré flou parce
qu'il n'a pas de fonction adaptative
dont je me rappelle très bien que je
plongeais sous le corps d'une dame qui
était en train de mourir dans
l'ambulance alors je croyais que c'était
une ambulance logiquement fait c'était
une ambulance puisqu'il y avait une dame
en train de mourir
dont je pensais que c'était une
ambulance et en fait c'était une
camionnette qui avait été réquisitionné
par les allemands parce que cette dame
avait reçu des coups de crosse et elle
était en train de mourir par terre et il
y avait un contrat entre le gouvernement
de vichy et l'armée allemande
il fallait séduire la population donc
les nazis ne pouvait pas laisser cette
dame mourir par terre donc il avait
réquisitionné une camionnette il avait
mis le corps de cette dame en train de
mourir et quand j'ai vu ça j'ai plongé
madame une infirmière madame descoubes
est-ce que je retrouvais grâce à mon
premier livre the années plus tard
quarante ans plus tard m'a fait si j'ai
plongé sous le corps de la dame blanche
et puisque je vais retrouver aussi des
années plus tard j'ai eu des relations
amicales avec son fils et sa petite
fille donc vous faites preuve de
résilience à ce moment là votre seul
objectif c'est de vous échapper
je fais preuve de copies c'est à dire
j'affronte le problème mais la
résilience et après le trauma pendant le
trauma c'est-à-dire l'arrestation la
condamnation à mort qui avait été
clairement dit clairement énoncé puis à
la synagogue encore plus donc je savais
qu'on voulait me tuer affronter ça c'est
dans la synchronie c'est le coping oui
donc en anglais tout comme ça veut dire
affronter le l'adversité
voilà c'est ça et après la guerre à ce
moment là je me suis libre maintenant
j'ai le droit de me remettre à vis ans
j'ai le droit de vivre puisque le
nazisme est effondrée comment je vais
faire
j'ai plus de familles vos parents
avaient été déportés presque toute ma
famille a disparu en suisse où on sait
par où dont j'ai un oncle que j'ai bien
que j'ai gardé longtemps qui lui s'est
engagé à 18 ans dans la résistance et
c'est tout le reste a disparu dont je
n'avais pas le droit belge avait pas la
possibilité d'aller à l'école parce que
j'aurais été arrêté si j'avais été à
l'école dont j'avais un retard très
grand et puis j'avais ça dans ma mémoire
c'est que on veut me tue jeu mais j'ai
pas de famille pour me protéger et vous
n'avez pas souffert de ça pendant la
guerre alors j'ai peur souvent
y'en avoir souffert de ça j'ai commencé
à souffrir de sa à la libération
c'est au moment où le calme revient
voilà c'est paradoxal non
oui parce et c'est paradoxal mais c'est
pas contradictoire c'est paradoxal c'est
à dire que logiquement je dû souffrir
pendant la guerre et être soulagé après
la guerre voilà ça c'est la logique et
le para doxa ce qui vit à côté de la
logique c'est que pendant la guerre
j'étais entouré par des justes anti
choses et de confiance qui voulez vous
sauver qui voulait sauver qui me paraît
gentiment qui me protéger je me sentais
protégé par eux parce que j'étais enfant
donc quand on est enfant le monde est
binaire il ya les grands et les petits
ya les gentils et les méchants ya les
gentils et les méchants
donc les gens qui étaient autour de moi
les méchants c'était les allemands et
après la guerre ça a été le début de les
souffrances
pourquoi parce que je me rendais compte
que je partais avec un handicap énorme
en retard à l'école un retard mais
pratique il est trés j'avais
pratiquement pas été à l'école alors que
d'autres juifs pouvaient aller à l'école
sous un faux nom
mais lui-même a bien montré que va dieu
les enfants quant au revoir les enfants
adorent les enfants que beaucoup
d'enfants ont été arrêtés à l'école même
certains ont été à l'école moi fait
partie de ceux qui n'ont pas eu la
possibilité d'aller à l'école parce que
j'étais des ménages étaient pourchassés
et j'étais des ménages est très
régulièrement et après la guerre je me
suis dit mais je suis pas comme le zoom
est ce que vous êtes boris cyrulnik
voilà et que gt gt pas maurice unis
pendant la guerre j'étais jean laborde
pendant la guerre oui j'ai eu un autre
nom pour que vous puissiez échapper à la
mort voilà et ce nom me protéger mais
c'était pas mon nom j'avais l'impression
de trahir mes parents et après la guerre
quand j'ai eu la possibilité de vivre
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais un
handicap énorme un handicap intellectuel
handicap physique j'étais d'une maigreur
très grande gt
j'avais un handicap familial je n'ai pas
de famille une tante m'a retrouvé
ensuite mais elle même avait été
gravement blessé dora doha par la guerre
donc je vais un milieu assez difficile
c'est comme ça j'ai dû réapprendre à
vivre et vous avez une histoire
évidemment qui est très singulière
est ce que vous arrivez à raconter à vos
camarades aux gens que vous rencontrez
ce qui vous est arrivé et donc ça
c'était impossible parce que non ne
croyez pas les adultes le déni a
caractérisé la culture française dans
les années d'après-guerre
parce que sur le plan historique la
france avait pas été glorieuse
l'armée française était partie en cours
en collaboration et le gouvernement de
vichy avait collaboré avait même
anticipé certains or dans la version
donc le beaucoup de français étaient
honteux de ce passage là donc ils ont
glorifié la résistance ils ont bien fait
et il y avait un optimisme que vous
soupçonnez pas il ya vu une gaieté une
joie les gens se parlent et dans la rue
il y avait enchanté ont dansé dans la
rue y avait pas de voiture donc
quelqu'un se mettait à l'accordéon et
ont dansé donc ça veut dire que c'est un
petit gars ont commencé à raconter le
récit de sa sortie de l'horreur c'était
quelque chose qui était insupportable
qui était blessant donc ils les gens
éclaté de rire où les gens ne me croyait
pas et dont je me disais bon ben c'est
pas possible d'en parler mais qu'est ce
que ça a comme effet sur vous figo
logiquement est ce que les
psychanalystes appellent le clivage
c'est à dire que j'avais une partie de
ma personnalité qui pouvaient s'exprimer
en toute liberté
j'étais par été une bagarre et une autre
partie qui souffraient en secret de
quelque chose que je désirais dire mais
que les autres m'empêcher de dire que
vous étiez obligés de refouler non alors
c'est un refoulement parce que le
refoulement et non rend confiant alors
que là j'étais hyper confiant je pensais
beaucoup à ça mais je ne pouvais pas le
socialiser vous pouvez pas le dire
donc c'est le clivage vous avez en moins
une crypte de douleurs de dangerosité et
une autre partie de moi qui pouvais
aller enfin à l'école lors des copains
jouer au foot où je n'étais pas terrible
peu et puis avoir des meures et
apprendre à vivre mais alors comment on
fait pour ne pas s'écrouler quand on a
quand même cette douleur en soi alors
probablement je le dois à ma mère c'est
à dire que maintenant a donc à cette
image là par exemple par lg c'est à dire
que on sait maintenant que les premiers
mois de la vie pendant la grossesse et
avant la parole comme ce petit bonhomme
sont beaucoup plus important que ce
qu'on croyait c'est là qu'on acquiert la
confiance en soi l'estimé de soi et la
confiance en soi aussi notre si on est
abandonné si on est malade si notre mère
est rendue malheureuse c'est pas la mer
qui responsable c'est le malheur de la
mer ça peut être son histoire son mari
la société la pauvreté la guerre c'est à
ce moment là ça fait autour de l'enfant
une niche sensorielle pour riis si la
mer est sécurisé et ça fait une niche
auriel protectrice et en acquiert des
facteurs destine de soi qui fait que en
cas de malheur on affronte tout cas aux
prises et ça c'est vous pensez que c'est
ce qui vous est arrivé probablement
logiquement mal c'est ce qu'a dû me
donner ma mère parce que quand un homme
s'engager dans l'armée française ce qui
était le cas de mon père comme de
quarante mille juifs en france se sont
engagés dans l'armée française et 40%
des fusillés du mont valérien était juif
alors que c'était 0,8 pour cent de la
population française ça c'est pour
combattre un autre stéréotype est
probablement malgré ça ma mère
dû me sécuriser quand même et quand le
malheur est arrivé j'ai affronté mais je
- affronter après la guerre vous dit
probablement vous n'en êtes pas sûr non
parce que vous n'avez pas le souvenir et
vous n'avez pas vu votre mère
suffisamment longtemps alors je dis
probablement parce que c'est logique et
que c'est mais le souvenir que j'en ai
c'est pas le retour du passé c'est la
représentation du passé
qu'est ce que les biens c'est à dire que
c'est à partir d'aujourd'hui que je me
représente ce qui m'est arrivé peut être
qu'au moment où ça va mieux j'étais
désespéré peut-être qu'au moment où ces
désespérés
c'est arrivé j'avais très peur mais
aujourd'hui dans la représentation de
mon passé je n'ai pas de souvenir de la
frayeur au milieu des espoirs d'accord
c'est comme ça que vous avez
reconstituer le puzzle façon alors il ya
l'attachement de la mer mais mais qu'est
ce qui fait que vous ne tombez pas c'est
quoi c'est vous avez des rêves vous avez
vous imaginé le monde d'après alors
après la guerre le refuge de la rêverie
n'a protégé et je disais le monde est
difficile je vivais avec doa dans une
petite chambre de 9 m² et pas d'eau il y
avait pas de chauffage c'était vraiment
très dur c'était l'époque où on mangeait
avec des tickets il fallait changer de
mains des tic et donc on mangeait peu et
c'est le réel était très dur mais dans
la représentation de l'avenir un jour je
serai docteur je serai médecin
un jour je serai écrivain un jour
j'habiterai sur le bord de la mer et
vous voulez très jeunes devenir
psychiatre vous rendez compte
mais pour quelle raison parce que j'ai
en tête j'entendais dire après la guerre
j'entends délire autour de moi que si
une telle catastrophe avait eu lieu
c'est parce que hitler était font
ensuite on a dit c'est parce que il
crevait la syphilis ou il y avait dans
l'histoire on racontait en justifier les
actes fous d'hitler par une forme de
folie c'est ça et pas par un système
voit exactement c'est à dire qu'on
expliqué avec ce qui se passait dans le
contexte dans le comté qui avait
beaucoup de six filets
donc on dit claudie syphilitique dans le
contexte ensuite on a développé la
psychanalyse
donc on a dit que les rites et
hystérique ah non pas du tout ensuite on
a déclaré des paranoïaques
c'est à dire qu on expliqué une tragédie
inexplicable par la doxa vous êtes
employé mot paradoxal tout à l'heure et
la doxa c'est une explication tout 700
rayonnement sans réflexion mais pourquoi
voudriez vous vous devenir psychiatre
parce que puisque c'est hitler était fou
je me disais si je deviens psychiatre
jamais ça pour en revenir il suffit
soigner les il se fait soigner la folie
des hommes pour éviter que le nazisme
recommencer voilà c'est un raisonnement
de petit garçon de 10 ans je retrouve
une réaction je fais c'est à payer 11
ans quand vous avez décidé de devenir
psychiatre
voilà c'est un raisonnement de petit
garçon de 11 ans aujourd'hui je tiendrai
peut-être plus le même raisonnement est
alors est-ce que c'était une façon de
réparer des autres mais aussi de vous
réparez vous même bien vouloir devenir
psychiatre
j'avais il fallait que je comprenne
c'était incompréhensible on avait tué ma
famille on avait voulu me tuer pendant
des années c'était incompréhensible
comment comprendre ça et je disais le
seul moyen de me remettre à vis et de
comprendre dont je posais des questions
je suis devenu un mec tu déjà pris a
lyon meme si je suis devenu un lecteur
effréné joli sens que dans les
institutions
on ne après guerre on nous empêchait
nous interdit lire quand vous êtes et
chez les éducateurs etc voilà parce
qu'avant d'aller chez votre tante vous
alliez vous étiez un peu bringuebalé
c'est sa baisse et c'était la culture
était à refaire à tout était cassé
il n'y avait pas d' éducateurs ont le
métier a été fait c'était en les
appelait les moniteurs il n'avait aucune
formation
certains étaient très bien humainement
certains n'étaient pas formés donc ça
veut dire que quand vous avez eu accès à
la lecture que vous avez fait des études
vous êtes devenu un lecteur et vous avez
été curieux de tout alors votre cv est
évidemment très riche vous êtes devenu
psychiatre mais pas seulement neuro
psychiatre psychologue psychanalyste
éthologue du comportement animal et dans
les années 70
vous découvrez le terme résilience dans
les travaux de psychologues américains
comment est-ce que ça a fait tilt chez
vous alors j'avais déjà travaillé ce
problème mais j'avais pas su le nommer
résigne hall résilience et vous savez
que nommer les choses c'est les écrire
et ne lui mal dénommé c'est le malheur
du monde
or j'avais travaillé et j'avais appelé
ça enfants poubelle en fonte prince
enfin poubelle parce que les enfants
sont famille où les enfants l'assistance
disait ma mère m'a mis dans une poubelle
où on m'a trouvé dans une poubelle
genre je n'ai dit je suis un enfant
poubelle mais lui voulu rester dans la
poubelle alors que moi je rêvais d'en
sortir et en lisant un article à
l'américain de emi warner une
psychologue alaric américaine elle fait
c'est pas elle qui a inventé le mot
symbole atteint c'est même pas elle qui
a fait les premiers travaux c'est sol ni
de ces paul claudel le français les
successions de travaux qui aboutissent à
cela et cesser succession de travaux et
emi warner elle l'a fait un travail
clinique et scientifique magnifique
c'est elle qui a le mieux illustré la
possibilité de résilience et je me suis
les enfants chez les enfants c'est à
dire qu'elle a elle été envoyé par
l'université de maya de miami à wailly
dans une île d'hawaii où il n'avait pas
de famille avec la violence extrême la
pauvreté extrême et elle suit à peu près
700 enfants des rues et l'argent les
fonds le son coupé elle revient à son
université
trente ans plus tard elle retrouve de
l'argent pour les re voir ce que sont
devenus ces ex enfin sont les 700 je
crois me rappeler qu'un autre ou six ans
la plupart ont été massacrés bien sûr
pas d'école pas de famille la violence
la drogue comment voulez vous qu'ils
soient pas massacrer mais 23 pour 28%
d'entre eux ont appris à lire et à
écrire sans école ont appris un métier
ont fondé une famille et psychologues
entre les examine ces enfants ne sont
pas plus altérée que la population
générale
et elle en parle à michael martin qui
profère à londres avec qui j'ai eu la
chance de travailler et michael roth a
dit ses enfants quelque chose à nous
apprendre
logiquement ils auraient dû être
massacrés ils ne sont pas massacrer sans
s'en sortir ils s'en sont sortis
comment ont-ils fait ça a été le point
de départ des travaux sur la résilience
et vous ça vous a éclairés sur vous même
ce mot ce terme est bien sûr non parce
que nommer la chaussée l'éclairer et je
me suis dit voilà maintenant il ya un
processus c'est pas un état c'est d'un
processus
parce que les enfants et nous mêmes on
est toujours en cours de construction à
mon agent se construit un peu moins vite
peut-être mais quand on est enfant on se
construit à toute allure c'est
stupéfiant et je me suis dit c'est comme
ça qu'il faut affronter le problème si
je veux comprendre ce qui s'est passé
c'est comme ça qu'il faut affronter le
problème par la résilience
quand est-ce que vous avez compris vous
même que vous aviez été résilié je suis
pas sûr d'avoir compris alors encore
aujourd'hui je vais pas tout régler vous
savez ça ça reste entre nous mais je
pensais j'ai pas tout probablement pas
tout régler mais toute une partie de mon
développement d'enfants d'adultes a été
organisée de manière heureuse par ce
malheur transformer en contrainte à
comprendre lectures rencontres voyages
passer les examens et c'est ce malheur a
été transformé en plaisir de comprendre
résignant j'en suis pas sûr je pars je
repris après une partie j'ai réglé une
partie des problèmes et j'ai pas tout
régler je crois quand on a un immense
trauma comme ça on s'en sort on se remet
à vivre mais on règle pas tout en tout
cas vous êtes sur ce chemin c'est le
chemin que vous avez choisi dans 50 ans
peut-être ce sera mais quand est ce que
vous avez pris conscience que c'était le
chemin vous aviez commencé à choisir
avec la publication des mineurs à 100 à
ce moment là je me suis dit c'est elle
qui a raison c'est comme ça il faut
faire j'avais vu le pressentiment avant
puisque j'avais fait des travaux qui
contestait ce qu'on nous disait on nous
disait par exemple quand j'ai travaillé
avec médecins du monde en roumanie après
la chute du mur
envoyer ses enfants monstres et les gens
les roumains nous agresser certains
beaucoup de roumains sauver les enfants
mais d'autres nous adresser en dix ans
venu bien que ces enfants sont des
monstres c'est pas la peine de s'en
occuper
ont ils ont été abandonnées parce que ce
sont des monstres et moi je disais pas
du tout ce sont des monstres parce que
ils ont été abandonnés et à ce moment là
je me suis dit comment convaincre ces
gens et je me suis dit c'est à ce moment
là on peut très bien se comprendre le
processus
pourquoi vous avez choisi de comment
dirais-je diffusé et populariser la
résilience à travers des ouvrages plutôt
que de le garder dans un cabinet de
psychanalyse avec vos patients parce que
l'action sur la culture participe à la
résilience quand il ya une discordance
entre les récits le récit que je me fais
de ce qui m'est arrivé je ne peux pas le
dire parce que vous faites taire vous
vous éclater de rire quand je vous
raconte mon malheur je suis coupé en
deux mots psychisme est coupée en deux
si je veux redevenir entier il faut que
les discours soient les récits soient
concordants
le récit que je me fais de ce qui m'est
arrivé vous devez vous la culture ma
famille les voies les voisins vous devez
l'entendre à ce moment là les deux
récits sont concordants j'ai plus de
raisons de devenir coupé en deux mots
clivage disparaît alors la résilience
vous en avait parlé à travers votre
propre histoire dans certains des livres
que vous avez écrit et pourtant pendant
des années vous êtes tués qu'est ce qui
fait que vous êtes autorisés à en parler
pendant des années je me fais pas
vraiment eu luge et je me suis exprimée
par l'intermédiaire de porte parole mes
patients c'est à dire que il me faisait
comprendre des choses que je notais et
qu'il faisait un récit mais mes patients
et m et porte parole où je lisais des
livres le dernier des justes d'andré
schwarz bart les guichets du louvre
tous ces récits là me réconforter mais
je ne pouvais pas dire je
je ne pouvais donc parler de moi que à
la troisième personne
j'écrivais les autobiographies en
donnant la parole à un héros de textes
comme le font la plupart des écrivains
d'ailleurs la plupart des premiers
romans sont des romans autobiographiques
mais les écrivains dits jamais ça m'est
arrivé mais vous avez commencé à en
parler dans les années 80 donc il y
avait alors qu'avant personne ne voulait
écouter votre histoire qu'est ce qui
fait que vous autorisez en parler vous
l'avez dit parce que la culture des
années 80 changé et que tout d'un coup
elle est devenue concordantes et accepté
d'entendre mes récits et en quoi vous
faire le récit de ce qui nous est arrivé
est il essentiel parce que je suis plus
coupée en deux si ça vient gens pas si
ça vient pas j'en parle pas comme vous
comme quelqu'un qui a eu une enfance
normale alors que là j'avais
l'impression le sentiment d'avoir une
enfance normale
et pourtant il y en a certains et
notamment des rescapés de la shoah qui
ont raconté leur histoire par exemple
primo levi qui écrit si c'est un homme
un magnifique livre sur ce qu'il a vécu
dans les camps mais il va pourtant se
suicider des années plus tard
donc je me dire qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
combattre contourner vaincre cela voilà
c'est à dire que primo levi dit voulais
témoigner alors que moi je voulais qu'on
prend c'est pas pareil quelle est la
différence
primo levi en voulant témoigner
ressasser il racontait sans arrêt
l'horreur l'humiliation
on m'a pas considéré comme un homme
j'arrive à auch 8 + rencontre quelqu'un
qui savait que j'étais chimiste ss était
féministe comme moi il raconte les faits
uniquement
il raconte les faits uniquement pour
témoigner il dit comme mon livre a été
traduit en allemagne j'ai été heureux
parce que j'avais l'impression que
chacun de mes livres était un revolver
dirigé sur la tête de chaque allemand
il voulait pas métamorphosé il voulait
pas comprendre et voulait il a été
capable largement mais il voulait
témoigner raconter l'horreur dont qu'il
encourageait le syndrome
psychotraumatiques la définition du
syndrome psychotraumatiques c'est la
répétition
ils répétaient leur répéter la même
chose pourquoi on a voulu me tuer
pourquoi on a alors que faire le récit
pour comprendre c'est une façon le
transformer d'une certaine manière
voilà c'est exactement alors est ce que
tout le monde peut être résilié si si on
sait d'un processus assez pas un
adjectif
c'est un processus est une construction
constante qui fait qu' on devient plus
ou moins résidents selon notre travail
et selon notre contexte familial amical
et culture et si j'ai pas eu une mère
qui a été protectrice est ce que pour
autant ces fichus pour moi où malgré
tout ce processus peut se mettre en
oeuvre alors si vous avez votre mère a
été malheureux mortes ou malades ou
maltraité pendant les vingt mètres
trente premiers mois les 1000 premiers
jours de votre existence vous avez
acquis les facteurs de vulnérabilité
c'est rattrapable condition qu' un
substitut maternelle ou à condition
qu'on ait de votre mère car devenir
suffisamment forte pour vous communiquer
pour vous donner la confiance on voulait
steam de soi et après si on vous
entourent si vous avez un soutien
affectif et si on vous aide à verbaliser
a donné sens pas ce qui vous est arrivé
vous pourrez déclencher un processus de
résilience mais il faudra beaucoup
travailler
alors que si vous avez été protégé dans
les premiers mois de votre vie si le
malheur arrive vous allez souffrir mais
vous reprendrez facilement un processus
de résilience
alors on voit bien que la résilience
fait partie d'une des oeuvres de votre
vie et l'oeuvre de vos devis d'une
certaine façon demain
l'avenir c'est quoi pour vous boris
cyrulnik alors leur résilience aura été
le sens de ma vie demain je pense que
elle va changer de forme parce que vous
m'avez fait comprendre que il ya une
époque où la résilience était uniquement
la survie est maintenant dans un
contexte social culturel technologique a
tellement changé qu'on a une nouvelle
manière de devenir
un être humain et que les traumatismes
ne rompt pas sûrement cette forme là
auront d'autres formes et aviaires c'est
à dire que avant les traumatismes
c'était la famine la guerre la guerre de
coller gars de crouttes de famine je
peux en manger je vais attaquer villages
voisins où les guerres de croyance ils
parlent pas la même langue que moi il
n'a pas la même couleur de peau il n'a
pas le même dieu que moi donc il mérite
la mort c'était la plupart des guerres
ont été faites par céder aux grandes
causes la famine ou la croyance ans
aujourd'hui pour l'instant la famine et
contrôler c'est à dire que ça va durer
mais les croyances actuellement feu ses
parts dans tous les sens et on voit des
communautés des groupes se refermer pour
avoir des certitudes par des visions
claires du monde et à ce moment lampe
faire l'hypothèse que y aura plein de
petits de micro guerre partout entre
communautés différentes et pour vous
donc l'avenir c'est quoi la résilience
change les études sur la résilience
changeront de forme c'est à dire que
probablement lé facteur de résilience
que j'ai connus ne seront pas les
faveurs de résilience que devront
connaître les enfants traumatisés donc
vous allez continuer à chercher tout le
temps merci infiniment
c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]